good morning Hank it's Tuesday
aggressively unscripted video incoming
big day around here first off my new
book turtles all the way down has a
cover look it's right there it was
designed by Rodrigo Corral who did the
cover of The Fault in Our Stars and it's
beautiful and I think it really captures
the feeling of the thought spirals that
are at the center of the book and I hope
that you like it by the way this is the
actual cover but it is not the actual
book it is wrapped around Paper Towns I
know some people are disappointed by the
lack of actual turtles but they'll also
probably be disappointed by the lack of
actual turtles in the book there is
however this amazing jiff or possibly
gif if you want to enjoy actual turtles
all the way down okay also today I am
reading the final final final manuscript
for Turtles all the way down because it
is going to the printer tomorrow
this probably also means that I'm
reading the book in its entirety for the
last time ever because once something is
published and I can't change anything I
find it unbearable to read it so it's
kind of an emotional day because you
know for the last six years this book
has been mostly mine and after today it
won't be mine anymore it'll belong to
the people who read it and that's
exciting but it's also ha I mean it's
hard to describe the feeling describe
it's very hard to describe the feeling I
just really hope people like the book
but you know starting tomorrow there's
nothing I can do let's talk about
signing here's the situation I've signed
one hundred and eighty four thousand
sheets of paper I am on the first of the
two turtles I've got eight boxes left at
sixteen thousand sheets which will take
about 32 hours and I've got to be done
by Monday now I know I would already be
done if I have just not gone to Venice
but I liked going to Venice so I've got
to finish signing and then there is the
small matter of reconnecting the sheets
with their boxes there are a lot of
boxes in my basement right now and also
a lot of sign sheets how do I get the
sheets neatly inside the boxes well I'm
glad you asked I get to use my electric
jogger the electro jogger is this
amazing piece of 20th century technology
that exists solely to line up sheets of
paper and it is truly magical Oh on the
subject of sign books Amazon has sold
out of their allotment of probably
signed copies of Turtles all the way
down but there are still lots of copies
available books-a-million has a lot for
instance you can always find out more I
probably signed Turtles calm but yes
they are still available while we're
talking about books and I realized that
this video is a little bit scattered
I've been reading a lot of poetry lately
I don't know why I guess that's just the
way that my brain wants to process text
at the moment and there are two books
that I would really like to recommend
first is counting dissent by Clint Smith
this is a very small book but it packs a
punch it's got funny moments like
there's a poem called when they tell you
the brontosaurus never existed the first
line of which is you will wonder what
kind of precedent we are setting here
but at other times it's gut wrenching
it's sad it's just brilliant also solo
by Kwame Alexander and Mary Rand has
I've been a fan of Kwame Alexander's for
a long time but this book is really
special
okay so book recommendation signing
cover literally mispronouncing the word
describe absolutely no transitions of
any kind right there is one more thing
which is that Hank and I are going on
tour when turtles all the way down comes
out in October I'm so excited this will
be our first tour together since 2012 I
don't yet know exactly where we'll be
going so that information will be
forthcoming but it will probably be only
in the United States I know I'm sorry
but yes there will be two or details in
the coming weeks and I hope to see a lot
of you as we traverse the country
alright Hank I have to get back to
reading my book for the last time before
it can never ever be changed again I
will see you on Friday